how's it going sisters my name is
pewdiepie
i woman now men bad woman good
let's do this the white time felix
is a woman now grows up to her only fans
premium
in the next episode what is this pewds
top voted post
decides my next instrument me an
intellectual
oh hell yeah what is that i want it i
actually want it
well done what how does this what is
what
i remember this in primary school what i
never i never seen one of these
wooden percussion frogs you know what
you just slap it what is it
oh [ __ ] yeah hit that frog
[Music]
whoa oh my god oh my god i'm buying it
now
it will be mine yes yes
i should buy two one for marcia
i'm also ordering cat ears that now that
the woman
man i feel like a woman
oh girls they want to have fun
oh god isn't that so patronizing to
women
they just want i just want to have fun
can't do anything
yeah that's right i'm a feminist now
[Music]
billionaires if you invest in socks you
too can become like me
everyone invests in sucks billionaires
you weren't supposed to do that
i missed this completely because i was
playing minecraft
[ __ ] yeah well you made stonks
in real life i made stunts in minecraft
have you seen how much money i have in
minecraft here let me pull that [ __ ] up
for you
i look like such a karen dude my
encoding is overloaded what was
happening oh it's too much to have
minecraft running i look like someone
that's best friends with you but then
call your [ __ ] [ __ ] behind your back
oh girls
all right can i run can i run minecraft
see how much [ __ ] money i have
you see how [ __ ] rich i am that's
right anyway
yeah stick it to the man stick it to the
man i don't like men
[ __ ] you billionaires boomers [ __ ] you
i shoot you these are guns don't add
them in the
what does women use you women use guns
felix most upvoted post is the
instrument
i buy that's vintage he's so good
i love his videos uh pewds reverse
face reveal me reverse subscribing
no guys cocomelon diss track
very soon okay should i show a little
teaser yeah let's just say there might
be some collateral damage
all right that's another teaser
i can't wait to see it hell yeah
[ __ ] you up don't unsubscribe yet okay
just wait for the cocomelon diss track
and then
inspired by pewdiepie's latest profile
video i hope you all like it
i do like it but why did you draw this
it should have been pixelated like the
original one otherwise
perfect i hate titans turns into titan
i hate ghouls turns into ghoul i hate
vampires turns into vamp i hate v
tubers no well i
hate men so feud's top voted post
decides my next
instrument meaning oh [ __ ] what are
those called like an
oscillator or something that's not what
they're called holy [ __ ] that was right
they're called an oscillator
can i buy one oh they're not too
expensive oh wait that's not an
instrument
i can't be [ __ ] all right why does
pewdiepie's v tuber avatar look like
he's going to run up on me and demand
the pokemon battle
yes i don't understand what people rip
into my v tuber
character i spend so much time on it i
find youtubers very annoying not gonna
lie
i meant their voices they always put on
this hey guys
hey guys it's me tuber yeah it's just
weird
i don't hate youtubing is cool i i'm a
youtuber myself as part of the youtuber
community
it's great the end of finding dory in
swedish netflix is by
far the greatest movie moment in cinema
history it says salute
rinse and repeat so many films it's so
annoying
that this is a thing because i remember
trying to play [ __ ]
games online and you you try to write
like oh game over
like it's [ __ ] and and it gets censored
and it's so you're like why
you can't say apparently that's a sword
and as a woman
i take bad to that can i joke about
being a woman i can't tell
help me it's too far gone i might as
well commit also
disrupted bullying the owner himself
okay no harassment of any particular
user
yeah i don't like him i don't like him
it's pretty base but i don't like him
pewds
top upvoted post will be my next
instrument
don't challenge me because i will accept
i have a sword and i
can murder
there you go that's your reaction image
of the day
whole summary turn of force felix to do
a face reveal
yep pretty much
[Laughter]
i wonder what this is going to be then
[ __ ] pewdiepie getting selected as the
most handsome face of 2020 pewdiepie
gift cells stop
it's called quitting while you're ahead
okay i haven't been doing this
this is actually would have been perfect
to grow a beard
i gotten so many comments like did he
hurt his face
is he getting a nose job is he wearing
his beard
but no it's just a joke that i thought
was funny
apparently i was wrong anyway sweden
successfully tests wireless charging
road set to revolution
uh revolutionize mobility you're welcome
just say thanks
i'm not on board with this this seems
incredibly stupid wasn't there a
kickstarter scam or some [ __ ] oh the
makeup falls off when i do this and i
[Laughter]
they they were talking about solar
powered roads right
and this is a big old scam i mean i
guess it could work on a smaller country
oh yeah this is huge so [ __ ] lasagna
got more views than everyday bro
so british lasagna is officially as far
as i understand
the biggest quote-unquote youtuber song
whatever that means
i don't know but it's a thing i'm just
glad you guys
listen to the song [ __ ] i don't know
more than everyday bro though
pewdiepie basketball pewdiepie
basketball
what the hell is this the council is
real
oh that's cute uh what is this oh [ __ ]
made with a passion for tuber simulator
hell yeah so the boys and girls
over at our minds the developers of
tuber simulator
the lawyer winners of last time were
these three
and of course this will be added as well
so
if you have any other pixel art ideas or
things you want into your simulator
highest voted each week will be added to
the game
just hashtag your uh your title with
hashtag tuber
and you will become relevant forever a
lot of great posts this week
well done guys alright a bit of the same
jokes over and over as well
pewdiepie's face for a split second i
know
i can't believe it i revealed that i
have a face
i like your hair man hell yeah
well all the best on your journey pitas
all the best i'm glad i could help a
little bit i know what it's like to
start off as a creator online it's a
[ __ ] struggle
uh sims to female streamers dude i gave
you so much
please let me ride you
that took me too long no i mean this is
so
offensive uh because female streamers
like myself
i just don't like it okay delete it
delete
actually you know what i removed it add
removal reason
okay i was just joking can i bring it
back please
[ __ ] uh oops miss click
please don't remove okay one of the mods
will fix this
sorry study shows that girls tend to act
more feminine around boy
who they like my crush when she's around
me
good babe puppy glory i face with you
[Laughter]
pewdiepie face reveal oh [ __ ] turn on
the camera
for the first time i play amnesia
and minecraft online guys go go
subscribe to bad history please they're
also helping us out with the coco melon
uh
music video so please amazing stuff
if you do it i will make a fix reveal
okay wait ice sculpture
what's with like people making pewdiepie
related
career crafts i i don't want to be
i won't be mean but he doesn't strike me
as the kind of guy that would watch my
videos you know
i mean that's [ __ ] cool don't get me
wrong it was like that cake lady that
was like i don't really know who
pewdiepie is
but someone someone said
in the comments so i made it can we send
this to pity pack
oh thank you you did it for me
thank you the [ __ ] is this it's like i
retired or some [ __ ] dude i'm 31 i'm as
old
i'm as old as jack and mark what the
[ __ ] is this hell
yeah no
it i don't like
no big pee pee anymore from now on
big boob big
i give this big bubba you're welcome you
have big bubba now
here you go felix yes excellent
thank you 10 out of 10. big boob bye you
get big boob bye
i keep trying to connect with laser lava
but
his time zone is just completely fine
compared to mine
and he works very long hours so he can
buy more g
fuel which is understandable uh but soon
hopefully
i'm a short sky i need to show off my
legs but people always judge you when
you go out in public with shorts
[ __ ] jacksepticeye no matter
how cold it is outside this
oh hell no
i can't believe jack is short shaming me
women can wear whatever they want okay
all right that's the way thanks for
watching guys see you in the next
minecraft
[Music]
[Music]
buff i'm